and our shoutout tonight for a
journalist working for Mother Jones
magazine who went undercover in a
potentially very dangerous place inside
a private for-profit prison a place that
this worked hard to keep journalists and
the public from knowing exactly what's
going on inside their walls the
assignment was to get hired as a guard
inside this privately run prison known
as the wind Correctional Center in
Winfield Louisiana so you know I'm gonna
be in there for eight hours a day and
then soon after that I'm gonna be in
there for 12 hours a day
this prison is crazy beyond anything I
ever imagined 1,500 inmates overseen by
guards making $9 an hour mother jones
reporter Shane Bauer was quickly hired
my my first day of training he's the
head of training said to us that at CCA
we'll hire anybody she said you know
people people say say that we're
scraping the bottom of the barrel but
we're not but if you have a driver's
license and are breathing and are
willing to work then we're willing to
hire you
[Music]
get out if you really care about
yourself expose potential inside a place
of chaos and violence all captured on
video by Bauer with a camera hidden in
his watch that he smuggled inside I was
surprised with how kind of bare-bones
the operation was you know there was
very little staff there were you know
maybe twenty five guards for 1,500
prisoners which kind of leads the prison
to be more violence than other prisons
in the state there was an escape while I
was there in the middle of the day he
went up to finish got on roof of the
building the prison staff didn't
actually know that he escaped for
two-three hours not enough people for
security and Bauer says the prison
company cut corners on medical care for
the prisoners by actually my first and
the president met a man who prisoner who
had lost his legs and fingers to
gangrene Bauer says the company is slow
to send anyone to an outside hospital
because it has to pay the bill what kind
of picture picture what you took here
don't belong be yours cover was finally
blown when a photographer for Mother
Jones James West was spotted outside the
prison taking exterior shots at
sheriff's department deputies demanded
to see what was on his camera I think
the best time to seize his camera I will
take it we found out later that someone
at the Sheriff's Department had searched
James's video without a warrant and on
that video was an interview that he had
done with me that day talking about
working in the prison so they were able
to kind of connect that that I was you
know journalists
were quickly moved out calling in his
resignation to the prison company I'm
actually calling because I decided to
resign Bauer's stories in Mother Jones
and a subsequent book got the attention
of the US Department of Justice and
shortly afterwards the Obama
administration announced that they were
going to stop using private prisons on
the federal level this of course is
reversed as soon as Donald Trump became
president so now it's kind of you know
it's back to where it was before all the
more reason that Bauer's undercover
reporting is now so important yeah I
mean we have a rich tradition of
undercover journalism in this country
and it's only in the last couple decades
that we haven't seen it as much and I
think that we have a right to see you
know when companies are serving as
public institutions what they're doing
and if they're not going to allow us
access then we have to figure out how to
get it in a statement the company that
ran that prison at the time now known as
core civic said Bauer's conduct was
reckless could have jeopardized safety
and security and that he obtained
employment under false pretenses but
Ana's application Bauer did describe
himself as a writer and use the name of
the mother Joran's parent company as his
employer so that seems very much on the
up-and-up most telling the statement did
not address in any way the appalling
conditions Bauer discovered inside the
prison which is no longer owned by that
same company so our shout out tonight
for Shane Bauer and Mother Jones for
allowing Americans to see what happens
with important public services and
functions are turned over to companies
whose first priority is to make a profit
it's not a pretty fixture that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us
we'll see you back here again next week
good night